slamming our meeting often finds himself
packing things people tend to need at
the last minute like printer cartridges
nappies or charger connections but an
increasing number of customers are
turning to Amazon for their daily
shopping needs - yeah - you know this
bags fairly typical because it's got the
kind of things your average consumer
normally buys in a supermarket ankle
Amazon's out to target city dwellers
like those with long working hours or
mothers without cars it's even rented a
distribution center in the middle of
Berlin a company first obviously we have
minimum requirements we need dry storage
space where we can store groceries
properly where we can install coolers
and deep freeze facilities that means we
have to cut down the possibilities but
places like that are available you just
have to find them if the actual decision
involves many factors in fact one would
under I don't get often yet not all
products kept in Amazon's main
distribution center are available here
but if they're on hand they can be
delivered quickly the surcharge ensures
a customer gets their order inside an
hour dispatchers monitor the traffic
situation to avoid traffic jams location
is very important from a logistics point
of view it means we can operate from the
city center into the broader suburbs so
that we can cover the largest possible
area and reach customers in the north
south east and the West
Amazon also wanted to open a
distribution center on the ground floor
of this office complex in Hamburg Sankyo
district the delivery traffic would have
come and gone by the residential area
behind the buildings faced with a
massive increase in road traffic
residents shut down the proposal this is
a purely residential area the speed
limits 30 kilometers are now with very
narrow streets
we've got child day centres retirement
homes and blind persons trust it's the
last place you want delivery traffic
Amazon argues that in Berlin it uses
electrically driven bicycle transport
wherever it can basically take traffic
off the roads
we sort of steer the logistics complex
into the green zone Quinn buffets but
only partly just 1/3 of deliveries here
arrive by bike vans II used to supply
customers living further afield